at seven o'clock this morning is ready
forces went into the West Bank city of
Nablus to catch the gunman who killed
three British Israelis last month
during the operation which lasted around
an hour three Palestinians were shot
dead in a gun battle the two suspects
and the man accused of hiding them
we were tremendously comforted by the uh
thought that they were apprehended and
eliminated and that everybody in the
Western World can effectively sleep
safer in their beds tonight therefore
the Israeli Army has done tremendous uh
kindness to the World by taking out two
people who could theoretically go and
bomb uh New York London Paris Tel Aviv
and kill many more innocent civilians
Lucy D and two of her daughters Maya and
Rina were shot dead in their car whilst
driving through the West Bank on their
way to a family Passover holiday in
April although they had lived in Israel
for many years the family held Jewel
British nationality Lucy and Leo met at
Oxford University and worked in London
for a long time Lucy D agreed to donate
her organs after her death they have
saved the lives of five people already
including an Arab Israeli and this week
the surviving children heard the
heartbeat of their mother in the patient
who received it they found it very
emotional what I found very emotional
was that the lady who received the heart
was referred to as little but when she
met me she said by the way my name is
actually Rina little
and I found them very powerful and the
mother of the boy who received the liver
told me my name is Maya so we had a Maya
and we had arena in the room and there
we were with Lucy's organs living in
these people's bodies it was just crazy
and uh I don't know a complete mixture
of emotions
the killers were aligned with Hamas the
iranian-backed militant group that
controls Gaza the funerals were held in
Annapolis this afternoon the green flags
of Hamas on display it has been one of
the deadliest years in Israel and the
West Bank for decades but the Israeli
raid on Nablus brought to an end a
high-profile Manhunt that had lasted
weeks Alistair bunkel Sky News in
Jerusalem